[Musique]
l'état de droit qu'est ce que l'état de
droit et à droite si ce qui distingue un
régime démocratique d'une dictature fait
l'histoire l'humanité ait jamais vous ne
trouverez une démocratie une vraie
démocratie qui est pas assez sur un vrai
et tout droit encore aujourd'hui en 2016
on en a des exemples à travers le monde
l'état doit essentiellement c-53 chose
il ya une seule loi pour tous tous sont
équivalentes dans la loi tous sont égaux
devant la loi
le deuxième point le gouvernement par
exemple la puissance publique doit
respecter la loi doit respecter les lois
qui sont adoptées
le troisième point pardon et que les
tribunaux agissent comme rempart de
l'état doit les tribunaux vont punir le
gouvernement lorsque le gouvernement
viole l'état de droit ce sont les trois
fondements de base au canada en théorie
et j'espère en pratique on vit dans un
état de droit
québec aussi mais il ya des dérapages
fraikin dont on discute à sait plus
quand on en discute pas totale de
facebook on en discute pendant 24 à 48
heures et après on passe à autre chose
rappelez vous êtes montréalais la
semaine dernière toutes les histoires
d'espionnage des policiers spvm là est
ce qu sur les journalistes pendant dix
minutes pendant une journée ou deux
pendant des mois parfois même voire des
années on verra ce qui en sortira un peu
plus tard mais toujours et c'est ce
genre de dérapage inquiétant le plus
important feu le dis à mon sens je peux
me tromper mais c'est un dérapage dont
on a assez peu parlé pour des raisons
que vous comprendrez vous même c'est la
sphère d'omar khadr
tout le monde connaît maintenant omar
khadr au moins un peu vu ces citoyens
canadiens
adolescent 15 ans en afghanistan dans un
combat avec des soldats américains
il ya eu une embuscade à peu près tous
deux en fait à peu près tous sont
décédés sauf kader de son côté et de
l'autre côté vous avez un citoyen soit
d'américains en fait qui est décédé dans
l'embuscade
on emprisonne khadr et on envoie à
guantanamo à cuba
on pourrait se questionner à savoir oui
mais ce que la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant ne devait pas
s'appliquer ici sur les enfants-soldats
avait 15 ans
ce que le gouvernement canadien
gouvernement harper dit un peu plus tard
ben non ça s'applique pas c'est un
terroriste mais bien à guantanamo il se
passe quoi il se passe ce qui se passe
habituellement guantanamo
c'est à dire la torture systématique sur
kader qui a 15 ans 16 ans 17 ans le plus
grave peut-être dans cette histoire la
ceca dame ne sais pas si le ventre sais
c'est qu'à vert au moment où ce parent
n'est même pas accusé
rien pourquoi il n'est pas accusé c'est
simple parce qu'on a pas de preuves
contre lui on en a pas qu'est ce que le
gouvernement canadien fait pour aider
les américains
il envoie deux agents du scrs service
canadien de renseignements secrets qui
vont interroger kader pendant plusieurs
heures pendant plusieurs jours pour
obtenir sous tortul des aveux sous
torture terme est important on au top
sur et kader pour lui faire admettre
qu'il était responsable du meurtre
soldats américains en droit droit
canadien mais aussi actuellement droit
international la torture n'est pas
admissible en preuve pourquoi
l'épanouissement preuve parce qu'un aveu
suture savons rien
pourquoi ça vous riez je sais pas pour
vous mais pour moi vous pu m'arracher un
angle l état d'un certain niveau de
croire que ça tient ne se tiennent pas
et par la suite si c'est à melun déposé
en preuve les dames ans je suis cuit
mais la vue ont été obtenues comprenez
il est
demain les avocats de khadr qui ont
appris le stratagème canadiens demandent
à la cour fédérale du canada de
rapatrier khadr en disant qu'on a violé
ses droits depuis longtemps mais encore
plus depuis évidemment l'implication du
gouvernement canadien
la cour fédérale si effectivement vous
avez violé les droits d'omar khadr en
vertu de la charte canadienne et on
demande à ce que khadr soit rapatrié en
fait on ordonne le rapatriement de khadr
gouvernement fédéral vont en appel
devant la cour d'appel fédérale qui dit
la même chose que l'aco fédéral 16
rapatrier khadr j'avais violé ses droits
et pas n'importe quel droit la les
droits la liberté et doit la sécurité
est potentiellement doit la vie et
sérieux tout ça est ce qu'on a entendu
parler soit dans les médias appellent un
petit entrefilet ici et là au mieux
pourquoi mais parce que pendant ce temps
là vous avez quelqu'un à avoir un
premier ministre conservateur qui
répétait systématiquement c'est grave ce
qui se passe khadr est un terroriste
mais pour savoir si quelqu'un est
coupable de terrorisme j'aimerais ça
qu'un tribunal se prononce là-dessus ce
que jamais été le cas pendant ce temps
là il se passe à autre chose
aux états unis on décide enfin basé sur
la preuve qu'on a obtenus sous torse on
décide de tenir enfin un procès à kader
écoutez ça le procès a eu lieu devant un
tribunal
normal le pro sérieux devant la
commission militaire américaine qui est
un composé de qui va devoir c'est sein
d'un juge
un militaire américain de l'avocat de
khadr son avocat son propre avocat qui
se confiait peu militaire américain est
lui aussi pas mal le procureur l'avocat
de la couronne s'ouvrir au coeur de
pirate c'est un militaire américain se
vend et tous les jurés ce qu'ils avaient
à décider si kader ou non était coupable
d'avoir tué un militaire américain
étaient des militaires américains si
vous voyez pas de problème avec
l'impartialité du tribunal
vous stresser un peu chien qu'elle c'est
bon heureusement pour kader ironiquement
son avocat la deuxième journée s'est
évanoui pouf tomber dans les pommes en
plein dans certaines salles d'audience
et on avorter le procès s'était
peut-être pas une mauvaise chose dont
vous et moi parce que je pense que
l'issue du procès est déjà clair au
début de celui ci imaginez-vous le
pauvre avocat qui est obligé de plaider
défendre khadr devant ses amis jurés le
juge militaire américain est instituée
bref retour au canada le gouvernement
fédéral a perdu en cour fédérale est en
cours d'appel fédérales prennent la
chose en cour suprême du canada
et là il s'est passé quelque chose
d'assez etc et à l'ajout du mail début
des auditions
le ministre des affaires étrangères qui
est un peu en charge du dossier la reine
ce cas ne savent la chambre des communes
effet ce chrome et par les médias et la
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre
écoutez ça qu'est ce que vous allez
faire qu'est ce que votre gouvernement
va faire si la cour suprême
le plus haut tribunal du pays si la cour
suprême vous ordonne de rapatrier khadr
la réponse de cannes deux points on
verra
j'ai recommencé pour être sûr que tout
le monde bien compris parce que moi même
ça fait plusieurs fois que raconte cette
histoire
la chaîne cbs que je raconte des
histoires non sens raconte fort
malheureusement c'est la vraie histoire
on pose la question qu'un homme qu'est
ce que vous allez faire
si le pouvoir judiciaire le rempart de
l'étop droit vous ordonne au
gouvernement parce que vous avez violé
les droits d'un citoyen canadien en
vertu de la constitution vous ordonne de
le rapatrier qu'est ce que vous allez
faire répondre ou heroes et journalistes
aux thérapies merci donc à faire
d'autres choses ça va
la gêne hypothèse je sais pas si elle se
tient la cour suprême du canada
probablement au courant que si elle leur
donnait le rapatriement souviendrai une
crise constitutionnelle en sicile êtes
juge à la cour suprême vous ordonner le
rapatriement et le gouvernement refuse
de suivre votre ordonnance
qu'est ce que vous faites sept points
c'est la zet devant une crise
constitutionnelle majeure et vous voulez
pas ça comme juge quand le gouvernement
refuse de suivre les décisions du plus
haut tribunal
c'est un bris du lien de confiance et je
vais même aller plus loin et ça c'est un
bris du lien de confiance qui unit ou
sur laquelle repose si vous voulez les
toques droit en question est ce qu'on
vit vraiment dans une démocratie lorsqu
on peut violer ou cinéma l'état de droit
franchement je peux certes est alors la
cour suprême sachant qu'une crise
fonctionnent elles étaient potentiel
dissipe de faire la chose suivante elle
coupe la poire en deux esi gouvernement
sur violer clairement les droits de
khadr son droit la liberté son droit les
sécurités ça fait aucun d'eux mais
compte tenu de la prévert qui voyagent
en matière d'affaires étrangères et la
lsm thaksin est un peu devant par devant
par du recul on est située elle se
déleste d'une jurisprudence antérieure
bref des trucs un peu curieux là dedans
et elle finit par dire mais je ne vais
pas ordonner le rapatriement
parce que je n'ai pas en main toute
l'information mais je vais quand même te
dire gouvernement tu dois choisir ta
punition soit puni pour cela
mais choisit d'appui nition non vous
êtes condamné pour meurtre et la cour de
l'école
c'est grave mais choisit de punition non
on va essayer quelque chose
rouler à 140 sur l'autoroute à l'heure
en sortant en fait vous prendre à vrai
dire seul objectif c'est celui de la
faire et dit aux policiers qu'ils
arrêtent des côtes je sais que je
voulais à 140-150 je sais que j'ai violé
la loire c'est clair on faire une
affaire le rémois choisir ma punition à
quelques passages rec solar se pressent
pas avec ça puis après ça s'il vous
plaît envoyez moi la vidéo de la
réaction du flic
da je vais la mettre sur youtube
comment est ce que je veux dire
évidemment tout ça c'est a été reçu
comme un nombre de chaque pour les
avocats de khadr
on imagine ses avocats ont demandé par
la suite à la cour fédérale n'a pas de
sens ce qui se passe lors pourquoi cela
pas de sens parce qu'il est juif donc
avec la cour suprême saisie au
gouvernement tu dois choisir ta propre
punition services qu'un gouvernement
canadien au fait il envoyait une belle
lettre au département de la défense
américain en disant savez quoi d'autre
ce même jeudi que c'était pas gentil
d'obtenir la presse sous torture alors
ce possible d'utiliser pas cette preuve
là et là les etats-unis qui ont dû
verser une tonne dollars ont jamais
répondu
ils ont utilisé la preuve qu'ils ne
trouvent pas avec ce bout leur bref
retour en cour fédérale les avocats de
khadr demande à cette main pour fédéral
là le gouvernement aux pas respecter la
décision de la cour suprême ne s'est pas
uni suffisamment nous sommes utiles dans
l'eure et la confédération effectivement
on est d'accord avec vous on leur donne
de nouveau gouvernement de trouver une
nouvelle réparation dans les sept jours
qu'est ce que fait le gouvernement
conservateur faisant douter aux devoirs
tâche aux en appelle encore une fois
pendant ce temps là la cadette à
guantanamo
ça a beau être cuba c'est pas aussi
joyeux que sol il se fait torturer
depuis l'âge de 15 ans systématiquement
les avocats de ghadames ont raconté les
tortures que khadr subi c'est des choses
qui se raconte pas sur une vidéo cour
d'appel fédérale la cour zuber lors il
ya un juge seul qui a été nommé par les
conservateurs
c'est un ancien ministre la justice
conservateur
je veux dire son nom s'appelle pierre
blais j'ai dit moi je vois pas d'urgence
la s'apprécient pas mon argent sera plus
tard de tso font leur rapport j'analyse
la balance des inconvénients on peut pas
dépêché le gouvernement à faire un truc
ballon ça fait juste six ans de cadastre
la torture à guantanamo
donc évidemment n'est probablement pas
d'inconvénient trop important là bref
tout ça pour dire qu'après ces décisions
de la cour d'appel fédérale qui
balançait une audition sur le fond aux
calendes grecques donc beaucoup plus
loin les avocats de khadr et kader
surtout qu'avait-il ça suffit je veux
sortir d'ici ça presse
et là ils se sont entendus avec le
gouvernement américain et l'ambassadeur
du canada aux états-unis pour signer
l'entente comme quoi qu'il plaide
coupable il avait purgé huit ans de
prison
la prochaine année à guantanamo et les
châteaux serait rapatrié au canada se
passer un an les avocats de khadr
demande au gouvernement conservateur
bon ben on ratatine clients ou les
grands le canada dans quelle prison dans
quelle province et le gouvernement de
répondre quoi comment pourquoi on a une
entente
on avait une année à guantanamo qui
rapatrie au pays
le postier se noue mais si votre
ambassadeur d'ici là l'ambassadeur du
canada à washington c'est écrit là on
n'est pas lié par notre ambassade à mme
non vous avez déjà vu ça vous un
ambassadeur d'un pays qui ne lit pas son
pays quand même une autre formule
originale
bref après certaine pression on finit
quand même par rapatrier khadr sur le
tard on la voit dans une prison à
sécurité maximum dans l'alberta
et à chaque fois que khadr ont voulu
faire réduire le niveau de sécurité de
la prison vous pouvez être sûrs que le
gouvernement fédéral allait devant les
tribunaux pour lutter contre cette même
requête
vous pouvez être sûr mais aussi qu'à
chaque fois où kader demandé sa
libération conditionnelle
il faut être sûr que le gouvernement
allait s'opposer à lui systématiquement
aujourd'hui khadr est en liberté façon
contrôlée vie changer son avocat a
commencé des études pour devenir
ambulancier dépouille de problèmes
autres que ce que lui a fait subir le
gouvernement pendant cette dizaine
douzaine d'années c'est l'histoire de ma
perdre arrive demain faut dire oui mais
c'est loin de moi ça touche pas je parle
en afghanistan - va lancer des bombes
c'est vrai vous savez quoi je sais pas
moi si khadr est un terroriste ou non
peut être qu'il est possible mais c'est
pas ça la question
parce que s'il était mais qu'on lui
fasse un procès en bonne et due forme
devant un vrai juge et condamne mais on
n'a jamais fait et pourquoi on l'a
jamais fait parce que vous avez un
gouvernement qui a décidé que lui
étaient terroristes même si on n'avait
jamais eu de preuves à cet effet la
société obtenu ce torture c'est ça qui
est grave et ça pourrait vous arriver à
vous ça pourrait m'arriver à moi une
élection aux états unis dans le répète
déjà entendu parler cette semaine il ya
un candidat qui est devenu président qui
a promis de déporter des immigrants de
fichiers avec un brassard dit musulman
comme on l'a déjà fait dans les années
y a quand même été lu ça va piette en
place aujourd'hui c'est ça je vais
terminer en vous citant montesquieu et
ce tirage devrais je pense résonner au
delà de la sphère khadr devrait cette
fois nos vies à titre personnel
montesquiou faisait une injustice
commise à 1 est une injustice commise à
tous merci
[Applaudissements]